Home to one of the worst nuclear disasters in history,...
...Chernobyl is a fascinating look at how a city can change in an instant.
Today, we are headed out from Kiev, Ukraine, to explore this place for ourselves.
This was considered to be one of the worst nuclear disasters in history.
They had to evacuate over 150,000 people.
This is a memorial to the first responders, most of them being firefighters.
It's actually called "To the people who saved the world,"...
...and I'm imagining how brave they must have been.
We're given a Geiger counter...
...and this measures how much radiation we're taking in at each location.
The amount of radiation we're getting throughout the entire day...
...is actually less than a dental x-ray, so we are pretty safe here.
We've just arrived in Pripyat,...
...and this is the city where around 50,000 people were evacuated after the explosion.
It's kind of surreal being here.
It feels like we're in this post-apocalyptic ghost town,...
...and it's kind of hard to imagine what this city would have looked like in its glory days.